dimanche 21 avril 10h près de 100
coureurs venus de toute la france se
sont déplacés pour participer à la
troisième édition du grand prix de
montigny le bretonneux dans les rues de
la commune
5 us course assez amusant et des virages
des montées descentes à droite à gauche
c'est amusant a fait quelques tours à
l'échauffement et puis ils présentent
pas de grosses difficultés donc c'est
très très roulant ça va être très rapide
il faudra être fort pour réussir à
sortir et les coureurs de d1 et d2 se
sont élancés sur un circuit de 3 km
fermée à la circulation
les sportifs doivent réaliser 26 tours à
une moyenne de plus de 35 km heure et a
pas de stratégie fx parce que bon on
peut prévoir tout ce qu'on veut avant ça
se passe jamais comme on a prévu voilà
donc quelque part ben il faut sentir la
course il faut après ça c'est de
l'expérience
il faut qu'ils apprennent ils font des
erreurs et c'est dans les erreurs qui
est québec qui progressent après 78 km
de course c'est finalement romain barras
qui remporté en solitaire le grand prix
pour avoir distancé ses concurrents dans
le dernier tour à se fait toujours
plaisir
il y avait du monde je sais qu'il y
avait des bons coureurs donc il fallait
ça allait partir avec le avec le bon
groupe et à
et puis baleines dites pas ça fait
toujours plaisir c'est je sais qu'il y
avait du niveau c'est assez relevé donc
de finir premier c'est toujours
satisfaction
romain ba pourrait revenir l'année
prochaine pour remettre son titre en jeu
la compétition quand elle pourrait être
modifié elle devrait être déplacée au
mois de mars